new in theaters this weekend serenity
and a kid who would be king what will
you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
drunk my husband in the ocean for the
sharks McConaughey and Hathaway no way
way
serenity comes out this weekend this
Oscar winner and nominee filled thriller
tells the story of a fishing boat tour
guide Baker dill who is reunited with
his ex-wife Karen yay and she doesn't
like her new husband yay what she wants
Baker to kill her new husband
fun fact serenity takes place in the
same cinematic universe as fool's gold
something I shot just now this one is
for you if you like nautical thrillers
the ocean freaks you out you kind of
like it or like me you can't wait for
the unannounced Kate Hudson cameo also
something I made up right now you must
choose
what you stand for looking for an
empowering family-friendly film this
weekend then consider checking out the
kid who would be king the modern sword
in a stone action-adventure fantasy
story show just how hard it is being an
ordinary boy who gets picked on by
bullies hey leave him alone what happens
to be the chosen one to pull King
Arthur's sword Excalibur how does some
rocks in the rubble of a demolished
Building fun fact that's actually how
they cast me to host this show a fact I
made up just now this movie's for you
you're looking for an inspiring learning
to be brave coming-of-age story you'll
love classic stories with modern twists
like Arthur love Guinevere or you love
swords that is your weekend ticket what
will you see and check back next week
for an edge of your seat American
Mexican action thriller
[Music]
[Music]
you